for all of the women who are out there
covering the game for us that opened up
the door for myself sarah and alana guys
i mean just really an awesome day
absolutely i mean it's just been so
great to be part of this so great to
hear all the energy that we've all
gotten so many positive vibes and the
great thing is and you've said it a
million times this isn't the last we're
starting it and this is where we go from
here
i just think the biggest thing melanie
is that we were the five that were lucky
enough to be chosen to do this broadcast
but there are so many more women that
have been doing what we're doing in this
industry for such a long time and
there's so many accomplished women that
have the resumes that could absolutely
do this broadcast very happy to be a
part of it we recognize the moment but
above all it's baseball we are certainly
uh happy to be giving this broadcast to
the audience shane mcclanahan's here he
has one of the fastest average fastball
velocities among all starters
2-2 mullins finds the gap up the right
side that's a lead off base hit
and he gets mancini to chase his
fastball up and away first strikeout for
shane mcclanahan and two away
mullins takes off on the pitch
and they tag him out that's a 2-4 cedric
mullins a rare caught stealing
shane mcclanahan gets out of the first
inning john means this is his first
start back off the il this is the team's
eighth i mean he's just absolute
breakout kanji
rosarina gets ahold of a breaking ball
from means this one drills into that
left field spot austin hayes on the
retrieval a rosarina rounding out as he
heads in for second and it's a stand-up
double randy arose arena he gets the
race started in a big way in the first
vidal brujan switch hitter for the
raisin
and it's a pitch driven out to left
field austin hayes it'll split the
defense randy or rosarina helmet off
he's flying in for home the throw is
short
and the rays jump out a one-nothing lead
off of it
rbi
[Applause]
as meadows reads a fastball drive into
center field cedric mullen's heading
back to the track overhead catch
cedric mullins what can't he do but now
the throw goes over the tip of the glove
and the rays get vidal bruton to advance
regardless and you can see cedric
mullins a little irritated on the play
there after he had absolutely charged
out to make that catch runner at third
and one out coming home to wander franco
he's got a fastball and it's a drive
right to anthony santander the cannon
flashes to home the play at the plate is
not in time vid al brujan the wheels
it's two nothing raise as mcclanahan
delivers to anthony santander swinging
first pitch drive out to right field
brandon lau back he leaps he's not going
to come up with this one some dare
rounds first he's heading in for second
and the orioles with a double of their
own
smacks of all line drive into left field
base hit santander scores easily
orioles answer they've cut the lead 2-1
in the second
2-2 he gets mullins to chase an elevated
fastball mcclanahan is living on it you
know that that's been something that
oh there's a drive to center field
that's gone
homer it's up and rich hill calls it a
home run
there's your breakout offensive player
of the year right there randy rosarino
brandon loud he was all over the stats
on that rose arena home run as he swings
first pitch from john means it's into
shallow center field drops in for a base
hit as it splits the defense
and lau a two for two day starts the
fourth with a single
one oh and a drive into left field
getting up it's out
francisco
[Music]
of the year shane mcclanahan here to
start the fifth
and austin hayes gets fooled he chases
way out of the zone from mcclanahan
another strikeout for shane mcclanahan
here two away
pitch home to trey mancini he sends it
to right but brandon loud not cool this
time lines right into his glove as he
tracks it down into the depths one two
three go to the orioles andrew kittredge
takes over here to start the sixth
inning shane mcclanahan's day is done
[Applause]
and he's trying to beat out a sharp play
the rays
feed out brouhan absolutely laid out to
pick up andrew kittredge he gets the
throw off in time
and a photo finish
through first base here for santander
as troy immediately returned to cover
the bag
everybody's laying out on this one what
a play for bruhan
all of these rookie infielders and
they're just making these spectacular
plays i know there was the error before
but this this more than makes up for
that one out for the orioles and a man
at third for ryan mount castle he drives
a pitch into right field again brandon
is getting his work in this one takes a
bounce in front of him austin hayes
scores with ease
orioles get on the board they cut the
lead five to two in the eighth
and sarah as you mentioned lao still
adjusting to the outfield definitely
we're we're seeing some some growing
pains there for sure orioles trying to
put something together with one out and
a man on
and he lifts this out towards the race
tank it takes a jump in front
comes up with it mount castle is
charging the throw to the plate is short
mount castle comes home to score from
first
and santondar sends it into the raised
tank they get to watch it fall right in
front
a long double anthony sonton there
orioles finding life here in the eighth
so mejia stands in bases full of rays
0-1 mejia scoops ball into right center
field senator bones is charging diving
he won't get to it the ball ricochets
off of the wall coming home to score is
brouhan
meadows takes off as well he'll turn
around and wave around brandon lau it's
a bases clearing
triple
francisco mejia
and the rays have pushed themselves away
again eight to three in the eighth g-man
choi
2-1 and choi laces one into right field
a base hit mejia jogs home it's 9-3
tampa bay
diego castillo takes over
and he gets the strikeout here hayes
goes down on the slider
diego castillo closes the door and the
rays take it 9-3 over the oriole